very quick correction before we jump
into the day's news a few days ago I
played a clip of Andrew yang saying what
I thought was that he's not a big fan of
unions I misheard the clip he said he is
a fan of unions so I want to correct
that my analysis was based on miss
hearing that he said he is not a fan of
unions he is a fan of unions and I stand
corrected on that clip okay this is sort
of weird because weeks ago I knew I'd
have to do this next story because it
was obvious the redacted Moeller report
has just come out we are going through
it now and we'll have a report about it
for you on tomorrow's program but after
print playing coy for weeks now and
after pretending that the White House
would not be consulted about the release
of the Moller report the White House was
consulted about the release of the
Moller report the New York Times is now
reporting with multiple sources from
within the discussion that multiple
officials from the White House we're in
touch with the Justice Department having
conversations about the release over the
redacted Moeller report and yesterday we
learned that Donald Trump's lawyers are
preparing a rebuttal report which may
well be out by the time you listen to or
watch this the obvious question is why
do you need a rebuttal report to a
report that completely exonerates you
and the answer is as we are already
seeing in the Moller report and we'll
get into tomorrow there is a whole bunch
of stuff even in the redacted version of
the Moller report that doesn't exactly
exonerate Donald Trump and the people
around him of all wrongdoing
you only would know if your Trump's
attorneys that you need to put together
a rebuttal report if you have been given
information about what is in the
eventual redacted Moeller report maybe
even an unredacted version and what you
have to understand is that every aspect
of William bars handling of this report
has been disgusting but completely
predictable and this is a totally
separate story from the contents of the
report okay we'll get to the contents of
the report tomorrow when we've had more
time to actually go through it writing
and releasing a propaganda letter filled
dubious legalese wrongly suggesting that
there's no evidence of any kind against
the president which then is used to
justify Donald Trump's exoneration to
her playing semantics games and refusing
to answer during a congressional hearing
a few weeks ago whether the White House
will get to see the reports before
Congress does and now this of course a
coordination or at least conferring with
the White House about the release of the
report now explains Donald Trump's
behavior on Twitter the last four days
when Trump goes nuts on Twitter extra
unhinged we often later find out that
something privately was going on which
caused that Twitter storm Trump this
week focusing his anger on Bernie
Sanders and on Fox News for treating
Bernie quote too well during his Monday
night townhall Trump tweeting about that
a lot and then one tweet from yesterday
from Donald Trump just completely all
over the place continuing to slam the
probe itself and the steel dossier
remember the investigation has been over
for weeks and Trump is still tweeting
about it saying quote Wow FBI made 11
payments to fake dossiers discredited
author Trump Haider Christopher Steele
the witch hunt has been a total fraud on
your president and the American people
it was brought to you by dirty cops
crooked Hillary and the DNC how is there
any justification for briefing the
subject of the investigation about the
report summarizing that investigation
before Congress even gets it it's the
height of corrupt cronyism which is of
course William bars specialty if you
know the last twenty years of his work
on presidential cover-ups and more proof
by the way that Donald Trump knew what
was going on Trump announced that there
would be a press conference this morning
at 9:30 by William Bar yesterday before
the Justice Department had even
announced it
okay so Trump was interviewed on a radio
show on WMAL
and he announced during that radio
interview we're going to be hearing from
William Bar tomorrow
people didn't know that so the media
went to the Justice Department and said
Trump is claiming this and the Justice
Department said oh yeah we actually are
going to be doing a press conference
tomorrow so based on everything that is
known publicly based on multiple sources
familiar with the discussions William
bar had a very specific reason for
playing coy and not answering early last
week whether or not the White House
would have knowledge of the contents of
the report before Congress does before
the public does the answer was yes and
William bar knew that that was the
answer and therefore played coy during
that congressional hearing now we are
going to dig in detail to the actual
report tomorrow but the press conference
that William bar gave was an absolute
gong show playing all sorts of semantic
games you might have noticed if you
watch the press conference this morning
that William bar kept repeating that no
one in the Trump campaign for example
participated in the hacking done by
Russia was anybody claiming that people
in the Trump campaign participated in
the hacking William bar going out of his
way during the press conference to claim
that things didn't took place which no
one ever claimed had actually taken
place and we are going to see sort of
the full scope or at least as full as it
can be based on a heavily redacted
report with pages that are almost
entirely blacked out that what we were
told by William Barr in that initial
letter now maybe three weeks ago I guess
it was was certainly a
mischaracterization at best of the
evidence in Robert Moeller's report more
on that coming up tomorrow today's
episode is sponsored in part by the BRD
Bitcoin wallet whether you have
experience with Bitcoin and crypto
currencies or you've been wanting to
give it a try for the first time BRD
offers the most elegant easy to use
Bitcoin wallet out there it's an app on
Android and iOS lets you trade
cryptocurrencies store all of your
Bitcoin and crypto on the app totally
free send and receive Bitcoin with the
app use a credit card to purchase
cryptocurrency and it's 100% private and
secure virtually impossible for someone
to hack your account BRD themselves
won't even know your information there
are no logins no passwords you just use
your key to access your Bitcoin and
you're the only one who has access to it
it was the first ever Bitcoin wallet in
the iOS App Store they've been around
since 2014 they have more than 2 million
users BRD is one of the oldest most
established and most trusted Bitcoin
wallets in the industry we recently
interviewed Aaron from the BRD team and
it was a great conversation you should
search our channel for it and check it
out all BRD wants to do is to make
Bitcoin more accessible and simpler to
use for those who want to use it and
that's what they've accomplished with
their super powerful easy to use app
download it it's perfect for anyone
who's just getting started with Bitcoin
just as good if you already know what
you're doing I've put a link underneath
this video